Welcome back to Curious Archive.
This video is the third part of a series exploring
the incredible speculative evolution project
of Serina, the world of birds.
Serina was created by Dylan Bajda — a terrific
artist and worldbuilder.
I have links below where you can follow and
support his work.
When we left off, Serina was home to a single
supercontinent at the end of the Pangeacene.
Now it is the Ultimocene, the final era of
Serina — and one more incredible than any
that came before.
At 250 million years post-establishment, the
supercontinent has split into northern and
southern landmasses.
This period will see the rise of multiple
forms of highly intelligent life.
And in much the same way that elephants, dolphins,
crows, and humans — which as far as we know
are some of the most intelligent animals ever
to exist — all happen to live in an overlapping
time period, a similar convergence will occur
on Serina.
On the enormous grassland of the southern
continent, many key species can be found:
like the successful Circuagodonts, who look
unrecognizable from their roots as tiny fish
250 million years ago.
Giant Archangels flock nearby, a type of metamorph
bird — a curious classification that will
define the Early Ultimocene.
And scavenging close by, a large bumblebager
makes off with a young Circuagodont — foreshadowing
a rivalry between the two groups that will
change Serina forever...
But we’re not there yet.
Right now, softbilled birds, the varied descendants
of ancient water snuffles, are prospering
during the Ultimocene.
Organisms like the bludgebirds are now extinct,
but another offshoot of the mittens, the southern
squid stork (or squork), are still going strong.
These intelligent creatures are omnivores,
and use their tentacle-beaks to grab hold
of hidden worms and mollusks.
In temperate forests, another softbilled bird
is the shy and reclusive gmu (moo), a horse-sized
herbivore that lives perpetually on alert.
Why would a creature of this size be so skittish?
The truth is, it has good reason to be.
Elsewhere in these forests lurk the Grappler
— predators similar in build to the gmu
(moo), which are their preferred prey.
Their tentacle-beaks are lined with sharp
teeth and tipped with talons, making them
deadly apex predators.
A different branch of softbills are the terries,
a group that includes the hilariously-named
noots — whose facial-tentacles fused over
time into one elongated, fleshy mouth.
When threatened, these birds are able to scoop
up their egg and carry it against their chins,
where a small fold of feathered skin keeps
it secure while they flee.
A related group are the neckbeards, who like
the noots have an amusing name and carry their
eggs against their chins — although the
neckbeard takes this new extreme by having
a more defined pouch to hold their eggs: allowing
them to stop brooding on the ground at all.
In warmer forests, you can find the Lumberbeests,
the largest living mucks on all of Serina
— standing up to twenty-five feet, or 7.6
meters tall, and weighing over two tons.
This group, however, is in the decline: with
most now wandering the forests in isolation.
In the branches above, however, life flourishes.
Here, much-changed tree-dwelling tribbets
swing near the bizarre, tentacled boras — an
offshoot of the softbilled mittens.
Fantastic forms of life indeed.
On the subject of fantastic forms, possibly
no creatures are more unique than the changelings,
or metamorph birds.
Although metamorphs reach their peak in the
early Ultimocene, their ancestry goes all
the way back to the Cryocene.
The metamorph line began with birds that laid
small, shell-less eggs, which made the process
faster but led to their chicks being born
extremely underdeveloped — almost looking
like bird tadpoles before they reached adulthood.
Over millions of years, this larva-like stage
became more complex, with the tiny young developing
stronger forelimbs to move around more effectively
before becoming adults.
Other metamorph embryos were laid in the water
and became more fish-like, adapting for life
in an aquatic environment.
Millions of years on, the end result is perhaps
the most adaptable and physically diverse
vertebrate clade (cl-aid) to ever exist.
Among their ranks are Zebra tweezle, bumblebee-sized
birds that begin life as worm-like larva and
are among the smallest birds ever.
Another metamorph is the blue-throated boomsinger:
one of the largest birds ever to walk the
land which stands up to fifty feet, or 15
and a quarter meters tall.
Some aquatic metamorphs like the Longbilled
Pikebird have even abandoned their adult forms
all together through an extreme expression
of neoteny — essentially becoming fish-like
organisms.
Truly incredible.
Other metamorph birds have a somewhat unfortunate
lot in life, like the Dayflight Bird.
These extreme metamorphs begin as incredibly
fish-like larvae.
They then cocoon themselves in a silken wrapping
of their own saliva, which hardens into what
is effectively a second egg — within which
they metamorphize into adults.
Tragically, however, the adults lack mouths.
The dayflights therefore live only a single
day, during which they lay eggs to repeat
the cycle.
And if this sounds too out-of-the-box to evolve,
know that real-world Mayfly insects have a
very similar lifecycle that ends in an adult
form that lacks a mouth.
Perhaps the most impressive metamorph bird,
however, is the The Stormsonor — a highly
migratory archangel with a wingspan of fifty
feet, or over 15 meters: the largest flying
animals ever to exist.
Despite being larger than some airplanes,
Stormsonors are gentle giants, named for their
eerie, echoing calls.
As previously stated, aside from the metamorph
birds, one of the major themes of the Ultimocene
is the development of intelligence among many
animal lineages.
In the oceans, the herbivorous Ringnecked
Porplets and carnivorous Seastrikers are two
such examples.
Both species are social animals with keen
minds.
The Seastrikers have learned to operate like
sheepdogs, systematically herding the porplets
to create a consistent food source.
Considering how advanced — and similar — both
species are, it’s an unsettling system,
proving nature can be quite cruel.
And nothing is quite as cruel as an ending.
In the words of the author: “as happens
to everything in the cosmos from flowers to
stars, Serina itself is dying.”
The moon is starting to slowly cool down,
and it will never warm up again.
As stated before, the Ultimocene will be the
final era in the saga of Serina, the last
chapter in our great epic…
But before the curtain falls on Serina’s
finale, there may still be time for something
truly incredible to occur.
Over the past several million years, one branch
of the Circuagodonts has begun an extraordinary
transformation.
For eons, Circuagodonts have been unable to
feed on tall trees due to their short necks.
But now, one species has specialized a body
part that will allow them to do so.
Not their necks, but their ears.
From their hearing structure, Circuagodonts
have developed antler-like mobile limbs that
are able to reach up and hook branches.
An adaptation which might one day have intriguing
consequences.
Before that day comes, however, other branches
of the tribbetheres are also doing pretty
well for themselves — rivaling the birds
in diversity several millions of years after
crawling onto land.
Take the painted repandor: the widest-spread
canithere on land in the early Ultimocene,
whose jaws have a unique shearing motion that
helps them consume prey.
Or the thorngrazer, a hairless Molodont able
to survive off bristly desert plants alone.
In the skies, the branch that became the Tribbats
is also going strong: like the Blue-eared
Vibropteryx, a nectar-drinking specialist
that uses a long brush-tipped tongue to gather
food.
And in the seas, yet another offshoot is becoming
aquatic — like the Spotted Snailsmashers,
a strange looking group that feeds on various
types of mollusks.
Between the metamorph birds and various tribbetheres,
Serina is at an all-time high of biodiversity.
But now the moon is getting truly cold.
We are now in the Middle Ultimocene, and a
new ice age is setting in.
In this new world, only the most adaptable
will survive.
Sextacorn Thorngazers are one such species,
which have become thick coated ice age herbivores
with specialized facial horns that give them
a menacing look.
Despite appearances, these creatures aren’t
overly aggressive, just interested in self-defense
from ice age predators.
Another curious-looking new arrival in the
ice age are mammoth trunkos, descendants of
the neckbeards that have now developed both
a longer beak-trunk and a truly robust neck-pouch
to carry their eggs in — which has come
in handy in the cooling temperatures.
At this point in the ice age, the largest
archangels are sadly in trouble, as the rapidly
cooling world is making their migratory patterns
less and less effective.
Some archangels are adapting, however, by
becoming smaller and less migratory offshoots
called Seraphs.
Examples include the Ptundra Pteese, which
might not be as spectacular as their larger
relatives, but are much better adapted for
this new world.
Closer to the equator, a story unlike any
other is now at last set to begin.
Over the past several million years, a group
of Circuagodonts called the Antleers, which
have become more intelligent with better antler-like
manipulator appendages, find themselves blindsided
by a creature that hunts them with an astonishing
degree of planning and foresight.
These lifeforms, the Gravediggers, are a descendant
of the bumblebadgers.
While other predators evolved sharper teeth
or longer claws to catch their prey, the gravedigger
has developed a bigger brain.
They have, incredibly, learned how to make
traps by digging deep pits into the earth
with their powerful armclaws, and using their
beaks to sharpen sticks which they place at
the bottom.
It’s a kind of trap the Antleers are helpless
against.
But not for long.
By catching the less wary antleers, the gravediggers
are inadvertently selecting for smarter and
smarter prey.
And so the evolutionary arms race is set into
motion.
It will be perhaps the most rapid of any so
far on Serina — as well as the most pivotal.
Soon, one particular type of Antleer — the
standing Antleer, will become intelligent
enough to avoid traps: and therefore produce
gravediggers with more effective trapping
abilities.
In time, the antleers and gravediggers both
achieve sapience, able to use basic tools
and avoid each other.
While no longer predator and prey, a hatred
had risen between both groups that would define
the coming era in unexpected ways.
The Standing Antleers have now become the
Woodcrafters, one-of-a-kind looking social
organisms with highly expressive faces for
communication and exceptionally advanced brains.
Woodcrafters have also developed a whistling
language somewhat similar to the bugles of
an elk, and use spears to defend against predators
— although they themselves are herbivores.
Spears aren’t the only things they’ve
learned to craft, however.
As their name implies, Woodcrafters have learned
to shape the trunks and branches of trees
into basket-like houses — as well as fences,
bridges over rivers, or sculptures of beasts
or abstract creatures from lore.
For the Woodcrafters are developing a culture
— one that is in large part defined by a
hatred of predators.
Meanwhile, the Gravediggers are achieving
a similar level of brain-function.
While their marks on the world are subtler
than the woodcrafters — often little more
than art carved into the sides of trees at
the edge of their territory — they are still
marks of high intelligence.
However, the gravediggers are gloomily learning
to be careful when they make these marks,
as it can attract dangers...
The Woodcrafters, which have at this point
driven most predators from their environment
on a crusade to make a safer world, are now
leaving their territory in search of more
predators to slay.
Once the prey of gravediggers, the Woodcrafter
have turned the tables entirely.
Instead of acting in self-defense, they are
now killing gravediggers in a misplaced crusade.
Eventually, however, an incredible transformation
occurs.
As they expand out, Woodcrafters begin to
encounter barrier trees made by Gravediggers
who never learned to stop making art.
At first, the Woodcrafters assume these markings
are the work of some unfamiliar Woodcrafter
village.
After all, in their worldview, only they are
intelligent enough to create art.
But there are no signs of others…
In the words of the author: ‘The woodcrafters
had set out to create a world without monsters,
and it is only then that they realize that
they have become them.”
With the revelation that they are not alone
at their arbitrary pinnacle of life: that
the monstrous gravediggers they’d slain
for years are intelligent just like they ares,
spreads through the woodcrafter groups.
And it is at this time of cultural uncertainty
that the trajectory of the two species shifts
forever from a small choice.
An orphaned gravedigger infant, left alone
after the death of their mother — one of
the last gravediggers hunted for sport — is
taken in by an empathetic woodcrafter warrior-to-be.
This gravedigger child, aptly referred to
as ‘Bridge,’ is at first regarded with
suspicion by the other Woodcrafters.
Soon, however, they’d learn to socialize
with the group, displaying a personality and
emotional complexity normally hidden from
outsiders.
Bridge would forge a path for cooperation
between the two most intelligent species on
Serina.
The woodcrafters and the gravediggers, intertwined
since their shared beginning — would break
a multi-million-year cycle of violence between
intelligent predator and intelligent prey.
In time, other young Gravediggers following
Bridge’s example would abandon their territorial
ways and imprint on Woodcrafters, and the
woodcrafters would in turn accept the Gravediggers
into their society.
Eventually, the younger generations would
never know a world where the antleers and
the gravedigger were enemies.
And whatever the future would hold, the two
species would face it together.
So, what comes next?
Perhaps only tragedy awaits all life on Serina
as it continues to cool, but it’s always
been a saga of both the good and the bad — a
story of life and death, of extinction and
evolution.
In any case, for the time being, one thing
is for sure: the mudwickets and the bumblets
sure came a long way.
Dylan Bajda has released some content set
after this period, but I don’t want to dive
further into the future just yet until the
whole project has been unveiled.
So it’s a story which will have to be told
another time.
For now, this is the end of our three-part
series.
If you find this speculative evolution epic
as enthralling as I did, please follow and
support Dylan Bajada and his project using
the links below.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support and like, subscribe, and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.